LIFE AND NOT MY OLD LIFE IN THAT
CLIP, AND I THINK THAT
ORIGINALLY WHEN HE SAW THIS
PROJECT, HE WANTED TO GET IT ON
SCREEN.
IT REPRESENTED THE MISTAKES I
MADE, THE ALTITUDE I HAD AT THE
TIME, REPRESENTS A LOT OF WHAT
WENT WRONG ULTIMATELY, MANY
YEARS LATER WITH WALL STREET.
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HIM, AND I
THINK THAT -- WHAT IMPRESSED
LEO, I THINK ABOUT MY NEW LIFE
SO MUCH, IS THAT HE SAW ME MAKE
THIS RADICAL TURN, AND I THINK
THAT MOVED HIM.
AND THAT WAS -- I WAS REALLY
PROUD AND SHOCKED THAT HE DID
THAT.
>> HOW MUCH TIME DID YOU SPEND
WITH LEO?
>> A LOT.
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> COUNTLESS HOURS, HUNDREDS OF
HOURS.
>> HUNDREDS OF HOURS?
>> YEAH, 100 PLUS HOURS.
>> HOW DID YOU FIND HIM AND WHEN
DEFINED YOU?
WHEN YOU WERE INTERACTING
TOGETHER?
>> BY TELEPHONE IN MY HOUSE OR
HIS HOUSE, OR -- WE WERE JUST
LITERALLY, ONE THING I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE REALIZE ABOUT LEO,
IS HIS EXCELLENCE IS NOT -- HE
STRIVES FOR IT, HE WORKS REALLY
REALLY HARD, I THINK HE WAS SO
DETERMINED TO SUCK EVERY BIT OF
INFORMATION FROM ME.
AND HE -- STUFF THAT WASN'T IN
THE BOOK, AND WHAT WAS ON MY
MIND, JUST REALLY TRYING, YOU
DON'T REALIZE HOW MUCH HE'S
LOOKING AT YOU.
I SAW IT, OH, MY GOD, I THOUGHT
HIS -- I WAS IN -- IT WAS
MIND-BOGGLING TO SEE.
>> I CAN TELL ALREADY THE VOICE
IS PRETTY WELL PERFECT.
YOU DON'T LOOK MASSIVELY
DISSIMILAR TO -- I GUESS IN YOUR
YOUNGER DAYS TO HOW HE IS IN THE
MOVIE.
AND SO ON.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE MOVIE, WHAT
DID YOU FEEL ABOUT THE REALITY?
BECAUSE ONLY YOU WOULD KNOW,
REALLY?
>> I -- YOU KNOW, IT WAS
SHOCKING, I SAW THE MOVIE WITH
MY FIANCEE THE FIRST TIME, AND
WE WERE SPEECHLESS AFTERWARDS,
AND I WAS.
>> IN A GOOD OR A BAD WAY?
>> IN A GOOD WAY, I GUESS FOR
ME, IT'S DIFFERENT THAN -- THE
AUDIENCE SEES IT, I THINK
THEY'RE SPEECHLESS BECAUSE
THEY'RE OVERWHELMED WITH SENSORY
OVERLOAD.
FOR ME, IT WAS TRYING TO -- I
HAD COME TO TERMS WITH MY OLD
LIFE.
IT WAS A CATHARTIC EXPERIENCE
FOR ME.
TO SEE IT ON FILM LIKE THAT,
WITH SOMEONE THAT DID SUCH A
GOOD JOB, I LITERALLY FELT LIKE
I WAS SWEATING IN CERTAIN
POINTS, WHERE THE COCAINE WAS
BEING SNORTED.
I GOT SYMPATHETIC REACTIONS TO